recovery efforts will begin this morning
for victims of a massive fire and
explosion at a home in Philadelphia
at least two people are presumed dead
following yesterday's blast one witness
described it sounding like a bomb went
off the cause of the explosion is
unknown Don Dahler reports from
Philadelphia on how this all unfolded at
window of opportunity to rescue people
crews suspended their search efforts
last night as Philadelphia firefighters
continued to douse flames in below
freezing temperatures I haven't seen a
movie before it all began with a violent
explosion first brought down one row
house and ultimately leveled to others
Thursday morning surveillance video
shows the moment it happened report of a
possible gas explosion fueled by leaking
gas the fire erupted with clouds of
black smoke billowing in every direction
at least 60 people had to be evacuated
residents reportedly tried and failed to
save a man stuck beneath the debris
before more than 100 firefighters rushed
to the scene where they battled the
flames from the ground and from above
hosing down buildings from neighboring
roofs at least two people thought to be
trapped inside are now presumed dead
that was an incredibly dangerous
situation and
sometimes we do everything we can and
it's just in response to the explosion
gas and power service has been cut off
to this part of South 8th Street
affecting about a hundred 250 people now
the search will continue this morning
using heavy equipment but as they sift
through the rubble the death toll could
rise Anthony all right what a
devastating scene that is done thank you
right
you